and we begin with breaking news Metro
Police dealing with their second
officer-involved shooting of the day
this one happening in Summerlin near
bannery cross and Anastasia Loftus live
with what we know so far Sasha joining
us
Brian as you mentioned we're here in
Summerlin down the street from the scene
you can see pretty active scene behind
me here as you mentioned Second Officer
involved shooting of the day in Metro's
jurisdiction this is down the street
from Oxford Park if you're familiar with
the area again Anasazi and Banbury Cross
Drive right at this intersection quite a
few police officers on scene we are
waiting for information we're expecting
a briefing from officers shortly here so
of course stay with eight news now for
the latest now as of now Banbury Cross
is closed as you can see there just past
Anasazi so avoid that area if you can
here in Summerlin of course stay with
eight news now for the very latest as
this story continues to develop both on
air and online reporting live tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now